the husband of Scotland's former first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon has been
arrested Peter Murrell was detained on
Wednesday as part of an investigation
into the Scottish national party's
campaign financing let's go live now to
London Al jazeera's Paul Brennan is
there for us Paul what's this all about
well I Adrian it's a pretty dramatic
development uh this although the
Rumblings about the way the Scottish
national party has been operating its
finances have been going on for months
now at least 18 months the police
investigation has been underway Central
to all of this is the power couple at
the top of the Scottish national party
until very recently that's Peter Morrell
the chief executive who was in post from
the year 2000 until March of this year
and of course his wife Nicholas sturgeon
who was the leader of the Scottish
national party from 2014 until uh just
uh until February now the um allegation
that the police are investigating is
that it's essentially
allegations of accounting irregularities
there was around 748
000 worth of funds that were raised uh
in supposedly to be ring fenced for a
second Independence referendum to be
operated but when the party finances
were laid out in accounts form that that
money appeared to be missing so the
police have been investigating for
months and months now exactly where that
money went and how it was uh how it was
accounted for there's also a question
mark about a loan that Peter Morrell
gave to the Scottish national party
alone of around 107 000 pounds which the
equivalent is about 134 000 uh in order
to shore up it's um it's it's day-to-day
running costs so it appears the party is
in some financial trouble now at the
moment we don't know the details the
statement from the police simply says a
58 year old man's been arrested as a
suspect in connection with an ongoing
investigation he's in custody being
questioned by detectives the Scottish
national party is saying clearly it
would be not appropriate to a comment on
any live police investigation meanwhile
the governing body of the party uh has
agreed to a review of governance and
transparency
uh where does this investigation and the
arrest leave that the Scottish national
party then and its hopes for Scottish
independence
well it's been a it's been a torrid cup
a few months frankly certainly at the
start of the Year probably the last six
months for the Scottish national party
losing both its chief executive and its
leader in quick succession there had
been question marks asked about the way
that this power couple Morel and
sturgeon had had essentially dominated
Scottish politics and had dominated the
Scottish national party uh for so many
years and whether that was good for the
party and good for accountability as far
as the independence question goes uh
it's it's undoubtedly uh true to say
that the independence uh motion the
independence movement has been set back
uh not just by Nicholas sturgeon's
departure not just by the question marks
about the way the party is being run but
also about by public sentiment I mean
the latest poll that was out showed that
there is actually a majority of people
who would vote no to Scottish
independence if they were asked a recent
poll in February said that and the
Scottish national party holds a new
conference later this month in about a
fortnight's time to try to work out
exactly where they're going to go
politically so it's not a great time for
the Scottish national party both
politically or it seems financially yeah
it's new leader Hamza Yusuf says he
can't comment on live police
investigation but that it is uh today's
news is challenging and difficult Paul
Brennan in London many thanks indeed